enjoyed this man's work on Saturday
Night Live for seven seasons six years
in his new movie killing Gunther his
directorial debut he stars in him along
with SNL alum Bobby Moynihan as well in
Arnold Schwarzenegger it's good to see
Taran Killam here on the show how are
you so much for having me I'm excellent
you are let's describe for the radio
audience the Gregory that you are not
raped in right yeah I got my number 99
Rams aaron donald jersey on the five and
two rams your five and two lost five -
it's very exciting and you also don't
have like a a new-school rams this is
sort of like heaven can wait time
exactly
yeah it's my Warren Beatty throwback
classic classic yes true blue and gold
yeah so what is the genesis of this I I
am a longtime NFL fan but I grew up here
in Los Angeles and when I was younger I
was I was very into the Raiders the
Marcus Allen or bo Jackson how he longed
I mean just such a fun time to be a fan
and then they went away very early into
my lifetime and then in college I
promised myself if ever LA got a team
again I was going all-in and it was it
was serendipitous that it was the Rams
cuz the first ever sporting event I ever
went to my father took me to a Rams game
at the Coliseum when I was less than a
year old so that's a bold choice but I
know I know I think I was an easygoing
kid or it was just like the noise of the
Coliseum would drown out my screams
infant child being brought to a Coliseum
and for a Rams game yes sir yeah yeah
and so it's been fun so as soon as it
was announced they're back I was all-in
and season ticket-holder I've been to
almost every home game yeah oh yeah yeah
so your your your diehard you're
true-blue I am thank you yeah I was
supposed to go out to London to the
Arizona game and I'm between here and
Atlanta right now I'm shooting a movie
in Atlanta so it just didn't work out
schedule Iseman plus it of kinda would
have been awkward for the man who plays
King George the third
exactly here in London right kind of
rubbing it in in sort of a passive
passive hostile way yeah but it the fact
that the Rams are five and two and it's
each past week each passing week yeah it
gets more and more real here he did not
win five games last year we are now we
are now five and two we play the Giants
next I'll let that hang there then we
have our Houston so are you are you
assuming come on the cowboy game was so
it was so huge because that was it
really decided any kind of momentum that
this team has was a fluke the first few
games or has you know McVeigh really
like has he breathed life into this team
and I really think he has I'm hearing so
much more this season than under Fisher
not I have no beef with Fisher but I'm
hearing so much more just individual
players talking a press conference about
the team about community about working
together and in it and it's it's showing
and it's very very very exciting taran
killam here in the Rich Eisen show you
it would not be a problem if you had a
beef with Jeff Fisher I know like it's
it's kind of okay assumed I just don't
have enough of a history that I'm gonna
take that on I was at many a game at the
Coliseum last year where people were
really tearing into him and I don't like
that that's not Rick Dickerson being one
of them yeah yeah I got to meet Eric at
a preseason game this year and I that I
freaked out I freaked out is really
really cool because because he was
playing at you know at the game I was at
when I was listening you know so he
didn't remember me though which is so
insulting mmm-hmm but you remember I was
the I was the infant in Section D Road
14 yeah no but but I was invited to the
Rams practice the week after Fisher was
like go and were you there I was at the
practice I was there hanging out and and
it was it was a gloomy afternoon it's
gotta be awkward it was very I was like
really excited you guys are back and
they're like here's a pair of receiving
gloves
go on down the road yeah Taran kill him
here on the Rich Eisen show so your time
on SNL you you didn't you didn't kick
the tires in the Jets of the Giants why
I attempted because literally my first
season was the Hard Knocks season of the
Jets and Rex Ryan's Jets and and Sanchez
was there and Sanchez came and was a
guest on the show and I tried I tried
with them I was like this is fun and I
don't have a team and you know but uh
but it was tough SNL he came he did a
guest spot I think he was actually on it
a season before I was there I think he I
think Tina Fey host did and he came and
did a walk-on in the monologue Sanchez
yeah hard to play professional football
it is that it's so hard there's no
question about yeah I know yeah I know
certainly when again the Rams again five
and two right here in this season so
tell me about killing Gunther starring
Arnold Schwarzenegger how did you get
Arnold to do a comedy with you and Bobby
Moynihan your wife Cobie Smulders as
well as in this job yeah it was I mean
it was I don't know I still don't really
understand it I had I had made video
offers for a couple of actors who had
hosted SNL yes and I thought because of
the personal connection they would be
like oh Terrans doing a movie because
the role of Gunther is kind of like a
third act reveal he's the villain so it
only worked like a week and someone
could do me a favor and the second actor
we offered it to the agent that
represents him also represents Arnold
and said would you consider Arnold
Schwarzenegger give me negative five
minutes yes yeah and I couldn't believe
it and and the thing is is I'd called in
favors from people at SNL some of our
pre-taped crew to come film like sort of
professional-looking videos of hey we're
offering you this part and couldn't even
consider Arnold Schwarzenegger at
asphere in terms of accessibility of me
and having been a fan my whole life and
and his rep said you know he'd really
love a video so like that night I forced
my wife to stay up to like 10:30 filming
like like a slapdash
kind of like just filmed on my phone
right video and we sent to Arnold the
next day and he reached out and said I'm
gonna read the script and let's talk
about it
so did you what was your first meeting
with him like uh first meeting in person
I I went to his house okay he has an
actual like sand camouflage Hummer in
his driveway
he has like huge dogs and as I walk up
to like meet him beside his pool he's
tall he's like FaceTime you're skyping
with someone in Austria so he's speaking
German he was like so intimidating a box
of cigars on the table but but he was
great in the end he really responded to
the script and he'd been looking to do a
comedy because I think like the last
Ernest comedy did was like jingle all
the way which is a long time ago now in
the 90s and he got and I was saying to
him like it was so fortuitous that he
was interested in his name came across
because the role of Gunther I said if we
can just capture part of your essence
from pumping iron yes of that charming
like hate to love him you know like
million-dollar smile bully that's
exactly what this guy is and and the
movie is in sort of a documentary style
so it was really fun killing Gunther
limited theatrical release right now in
a theater near you you can check it out
video on demand on September 22nd is
when that came out as well night school
you're in with Kevin Hart comments right
sure is that movie in Atlanta in Atlanta
right now yeah Kevin Hart Tiffany
Haddish Rob Riggle Marilyn Rice cabal
magical it's a good cast it's really
it's gonna be a good one the Riggle is a
big jeeps fan I know I know we've been
swapping we did Monday Night Football
for him a couple weeks back where they
were they squeaked out the W at the end
there and then yep and then you're you
know you're friends with Joe Manganiello
who's been on this show as well yes did
you remind him taran killam that you're
rams have the same record as his
Steelers no I will though I will I
haven't I'm supposed to go over to his
house on Sunday to create a Dungeons &
Dragons character okay no say what what
what do you mean the Dungeons & Dragons
character Joe Manganiello is is deep in
the community of Dungeons & Dragons of
D&D and has invited me because we share
a love of all things nerdy comic books
and fantasy and stuff so he's going to
help me design my own first ever
Dungeons & dragon
character and I'm going to join his
league his guild his his his League of
his yeah so Joe Manganiello said that
yeah Alcide I'm very confused
you know mr. mr. Magic Mike yes okay
yeah six live 225
yeah those from steel oak I think he I
think he oversees a dark magic dragon
mage or something like that oh now is
sofia vergara you know i don't think she
says involved in the D&D i think that i
think she calls that me time that's
funny so check out killing killing
gunther taran killam man I love meeting
you and I get your interests thank you
so much for coming in here sir and on
behalf of all my Hamilton crazed family
attaboy what a dude rates great
performances King George the third
thanks man you got it Taran Killam on
Twitter as well check out killing
Gunther for more Rich Eisen show tuned -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Rich Eisen show app